dimanche 9 avril 1978 no 27
une pile du pont s'affaisse lors du
passage d'une voiture c'est le début
d'une lente agonie qui durera jusqu'au 3
mai au total quatre piles effondré soit
un peu plus d'un quart de l'ouvragé pour
les tourangeaux c'est un vrai choc
cet effondrement était presque vécu
comme un deuil les lettons ont cru
assister à la mort c'était ma m'indiquer
dans les journaux de l'époque c'était la
mort du pont et ça s'est fait en direct
résultat de la lente érosion des piles
par le mouvement de l'eau cet
effondrement fait suite à un premier en
1778 pendant sa construction
puis un second en 1789 mais le troisième
et le plus impressionnant puisqu'il
s'est déroulée sous les yeux ébahis des
journalistes qui ont relaté l'événement
jusqu'en russie et de ce bien sûr des
tourangeaux amassés ont pas c'est vrai
que ça fait un drôle d'effet je dois
vous dire que tout de suite on pense aux
dires de l'année heureusement qu'il n'y
avait pas une voiture ou des gens au
moment où ça s'est effondré j'étais pour
le plus joli de tours un pont qui
servait au transport des voitures bien
sûr mais aussi de l'eau et des câbles
téléphoniques à l'étranger eu la
désagréable sensation de se sentir à
nouveau en période de guerre sans eau
sans communication et avec un pont
effondré
dès lors la solidarité s'organise afin
que chacun soit ravitailler pour moi on
s'est arrangé j'avais une femme de
ménage qui vous descendez de l'eau parce
qu'elles habitaient en dehors de la
ville
donc elle me descend d'aidé
j'avais cân tho ensuite jean royer
proposera un référendum pour que les
tourangeaux choisissent entre un pont
métallique un pont en béton
une restauration à l'identique et une
reconstruction en béton armé avec un
parement pour les rendre son aspect
initial
c'est cette quatrième option qui
remportera le plus de suffrages le
wilson bar présente lui-même tout
l'histoire de la ville de tours et
toutes les vicissitudes qu a connue la
ville de tours et à chaque fois il
ressort de ces rumeurs
phoenix sont qui tournerait plus le même
visage
mais pour les plus attentifs un détail
permet de voir les marques de l'histoire
sur les partie reconstruite lapierre n'a
pas tout à fait la même couleur